FIRST START AS A  HUH, JOHN?
BINNINGTON ON PHILIPPE MYERS.
>> Darren: MYERS DOES A GOOD JOB
OF GETTING UP I
HE COULD HAVE SKATED THAT OUT TO
LEFT WING.
I KNOW IT'S EASY FROM UP HERE B.
BOZAK NEAR THE LINE, LAST YEAR
NOT IN THE BLUES DIVISION.
NOW IT ISBUT THAT OPPORTUNITY W
SAVE DAVE RITTICH'S LEATHER FOR
RITTICH IN THAT FIRST PERIOD.
>> Darren:n:
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENCE
THOUGH THIS IS FULL SPEED AHEAD
IN.
THAT SHOT UP HIGH.
ARMDOWN.
PREDS PREDS GRANLUND
STILL WITH THAT ORGANIZATION,
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN ARS, WHO PL
NIGHT IN DALLAS, THEY HAVE COME
VASILEVSKIY GUY.
>> John: THAT'S PASS BACK NOW DE
>> John: AS PARAY
AREA, AND NOW BOZAK GOOD
CHANCE IN THE OFFENSIVE ZONE,
THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MAKEFREE.
GOOD PLAY BACK
ENERGY IN THE BUILDING ALIVE.
YOU CAN VERY PROUD OF TOLVANEN
I LOOKED OVER THE BENCH OF THE
NASHVILLE PREDATORS A AND TIPS
TOTO MEMORIAL.
BEAUTIFUL BUILDINGHIS PERIOD,
JUST INCHES BEFORE YOU HAVE TO
GET THE.
AND HIS PASAS HAS
COLTON PARAYKO.
COME OFF BUT THEY'RE GOING TO
STAY BUCHNEVICH.
>> Darren: YOU CAN SEE
POSSESSION.
AND JEANNOT TO CENTER ICE.
AND